hey guys this is Pete peppers and this
is another gameplay preview for a new
soft launch from King
this one's called Eden harvest and it is
a sequel to farm heroes saga probably
hear the song in the background there
and see the crops ease so it's bound to
be popular and it's actually a lot of
fun so I'm going to jump right in and
talk about some of the things that are
new here and let's see show you what you
can expect whenever it comes out and
full release in the coming months so you
could see that you know we cook we have
collection orders that we don't have
anything like a shovel that we can buy
yet or any rechargeable boosters like
we're used to in the irregular game this
one also can't be connected to Facebook
yet so you know it's definitely one of
the one of the early early beta test
versions but um the gameplay is similar
it's a match-three and there's a couple
cool features one of which is the super
crop seat so you can see here that just
like in soda we can match four and a
square and we get a super cropsy and
these are you know basically the same
except better because the number here
like the six it actually stays on it and
says to match it to collect it you can
see that sometimes our collections are
just four regular sized ones and
sometimes they're four super cropsy so
we have to try to make a match so that
you can collect this blue one but you
see how like when the numbers you know
this from playing the original game that
the numbers only last for one move but
on the super cropsey's they stay there
so that that's cool so you can make them
super cropsy with any any color the ones
that are for collections stay and then
i'll do it with the carrots here so you
can see the ones that aren't we'll pass
that on
it'll pass on the extra you know to the
to one of the ones that we are trying to
collect so it spreads out that way so
we'll set this up and now we can collect
our super cropsy on this one and one
thing to know while we're looking at
this level is that you can see that the
gravity is normal just like a regular
match-three where it drops on some
levels it's gonna be a little bit
different and we'll look at one of those
next and everything else is pretty
pretty easy to understand so far I like
the gameplay I like I like the original
one and I think this one has all the
same things that I liked about the first
one and these new features too so that's
cool this is show time this is the this
is what they call hero mode in this one
so we get to collect a couple extra
points before we run out it basically if
you have a lot of moves left it drops
you down to like three I think is the
standard and then it grows some of the
crops on the board so that you can get
some some bigger collection so that's
level two it was real simple you get to
see the super crop see there and now
we'll move on and I'll show you a couple
other things the biggest change that
I've noticed so far is this level you
can see has these leaves blown across
this is a windy level and if you've ever
played on rural games and you played a
game like I guess stitcher ooh is like
this and the one I remember the most was
released the creeps when you make
matches the the crops move in the
direction of the match right so it's
really windy on this level and it shows
us to make this match and then watch
what happens see how they move in the
door
another match so it says wind pushes
cropsey's in the direction of your swipe
so we're going to move this purple one
to the left and you'll see that the
board doesn't have the regular gravity
it doesn't drop instead it actually
moves everything in that direction so it
makes it like a four-way directional now
I think this is cool it takes a little
bit of time to get used to but the one
major thing that I noticed when I was
playing through all the levels yesterday
was that you have to pay attention in
the beginning before you start a level
because when you play one that has wind
then the next one if it's regular like
it takes a second to adjust to the way
things are moving around so other than
that I think this is an awesome feature
it is there's a little bit of a learning
curve but once you get it down it's
really simple it just you know it's just
I think what what makes the the gives it
the learning curve is that you know
you're used to playing pretty much every
game that's a match-three is the same
and this is slightly different so just
pay attention to which which way they
move after each match and then you know
you won't have too much trouble I'm
gonna go ahead and try to finish this
because I don't think there is a quick
oh there is equipment so I'm gonna go
ahead and quit this since you got an
idea of that and I'm gonna show you one
more thing to wrap this up and that is
the this is there there this is a
another feature that's on windy levels
and you think we have to collect this
nut right here it's a squirrel where we
have to slide the slide the nut to the
squirrel so so is used wind to move the
acorn to the squirrel so if I make a
match here with the blue that'll move
him that way
if I make a match with the yellow here
that'll move the that that way and so on
and so forth
so once we get them close enough
together it'll get collected and you can
you can still move everything
all the different ways to set it up for
yourself one of the things that I
thought about with this is that you know
I know in the higher levels in the
original farm heroes there's a lot of
there's a lot of these kind of features
where you have to move things around I
just think it in general it's a little
bit easier on this with the wind because
you know which direction that's gonna
move and let's see if I can get it over
there I was talking to you guys and not
really paying that much attention so I
guess I'm gonna have to step it up here
you can see he doesn't move unless we
make a match that's directly gonna move
the things around him so like here we
don't really have one so we'll just move
things down and see if we can get
something and moved into place it's not
looking good right now is it so we'll
give this another shot real quick it's
not that difficult I just have to pay
attention alright so we're gonna move
the squirrel to the to the nut and here
we go alright so there we go now we
can't if we move this you'll see it'll
move it through so that might move it
over that moves everything over instead
so you just have to think before you act
so move him up move the nut back that
direction and now we can collect it by
sliding him right over there
so yeah it's cool I think it's a neat
feature it gets more complicated later
for sure the you kind of have to move
them around objects and different things
so it's pretty neat otherwise you know
there's a lot of the same stuff you know
there's flowers
you know water buckets all the stuff
that you're used to from the regular
game so it's pretty cool I think it's a
fun one I think people really like it
farm heroes are so popular and they've
done such a good job I think with the
other sequel games to improve things
that this is exactly the same in that
thing
they do have coins here that I guess are
like magic beans but that's not
implicated yet you can see I have 7,000
of them I don't know there's nothing to
spend them on yet
rancid is a little bit different I'm not
gonna go into that now because that
would make the video longer but it's not
like defeat the rancid levels like they
used to be you can get a bonus for
beating him on levels where he is and he
kind of moves around I think a little
bit but um you don't have to defeat him
to get past those levels like you used
to so check it out leave a comment if
you have any questions make sure you
like the video share it subscribe to my
channel to get more info on this I'll
put a link at the top to the new rescue
click rescue clicker gameplay that I
made yesterday that is another new game
and that's in the Pet Rescue saga series
that's out I'm sure you've already seen
the jelly saga it's in you know you can
go to my channel and see that we have
all the levels for that and we'll be
making new videos all the time so see
you soon